Short and sweet number 10. We proceeded to discuss all the many possible reasons why we can permit buying and drinking sherry cast whiskey.
So first of all, in the problem that we presented of bitul, of the Shach's opinion that a person would need 60 times the sherry flavor to allow the whiskey,
That was the Shach's opinion, but the Shulchan Aruch and the Taz both disagree, and they hold that only a ratio of 1 to 6 of sherry to whiskey would be required, and in most cases of sherry-cast whiskey, we would have a 1 to 6 ratio.
We also said that the Rav Moshe pointed out that even according to the Shach, in a case where whiskey is being used to mimibatil the sherry, and its whiskey has a very sharp taste, it could be that even according to the Shach, only a 1 to 6 ratio is necessary.
And even in the Shach's stringent opinion, we said that buying a second fill sherry cask whiskey would be permitted, permissible, because in the case of second fills, the barrels have not been used to store sherry wine for over 12 months, and even the Shach would agree that that would be permissible.
Okay, in response to the issue of an ingredient which is added specifically for flavor, which is never vatil, Rav Moshe Feinstein told us that that's only in a situation where the ingredient adds a significant strong flavor.
But in a case where wine is being mixed into whiskey, and Rav Moshe was even talking about blended whiskey, which is actual wine, but he said since it's only giving a weak flavor, it's not subject to this rule, and it can be vatil if you had enough of a ratio to mimivatil it.
We had another svar from the Mishnah Halachos, and he said that really a sherry cask whiskey, the sherry is not even giving flavor to the whiskey.
The whole purpose of the sherry cask is that the sherry will cover up the bad flavor of the oak barrel, and therefore improve the quality of the whiskey.
But it's not even giving flavor, the sherry is not giving the flavor to the whiskey, and that's why it would be permissible according to him.
In response to the issue of an ingredient which is added for color, so even if we do take that assumption that the sherry is giving color,
So the only time we say that it's not bitul is when it's being added for color and the ingredient is an isser de areissa.
Over here we're dealing with Stam Yeinam, which is only an isser de rabbanon, in which case it would not be subject to that rule and could be bitul.
We wanted to respond to the issue of the mevatl isser lech achila, of relying on mevatl isser lech achila to buy this bottle of sherry.
So we said two reasons why that's not a problem.
First of all, the companies are not producing this for Jewish people, and they're not purposely nullifying the sherry into the whiskey in order to allow it for Jews, in which case that would not be considered relying on bitul l'chachila.
Also, Rav Moshe pointed out a fascinating sfar. He said that the only time we say that it's a problem to be a bitul l'chachila is where the isser, even an isser d'arbanan, is linked to an isser d'araysa.
But in this case, we have the opinion of the Rama and others who say that the Yisr of Stam Yeinam is no longer linked to any Yisr De Reisah.
It's not linked to Yayin Nesech because non-Jews don't lie about it anymore.
In which case, the whole Yisr nowadays is an Yisr De Rabbanah but not linked to an Yisr De Reisah.
And that type of prohibition is permissible to be Mibatot L'Chad Chila.
Okay, the Halach HaLamayisah we came out for, Sherry Cass Whiskey, came out to be a pretty large Machlokas.
Rav Moshe Feinstein was quoted as saying that it is allowed, but a bal nefesh, a person who wants to be makhmur, should be makhmur, although Rav Dovah Feinstein reported that Rav Moshe was only talking about blended whiskey, but sherry casks, Rav Moshe, he assumes, would allow and would permit and not have to be makhmur.
Rav Belsky was very makhmur on sherry cask whiskey, and he said it is absolutely forbidden, that is the OU policy, following Rav Belsky, Rav Asher Weiss, Rav Mishnah Halachos, Rav Shalom Miller, all hold that sherry cask whiskey is permitted.
We then discuss grape juice, making grape juice. So when a person is in the process of making grape juice, the juice or the wine, which it ultimately will become, is subject to the isser of Stam Yeinam after the juice has been intentionally separated from the skins and the pits of the grapes.
So in a situation where a person is crushing grapes in a bucket, which does not have a hole in it, and all the skins and the pits are all mixed together, and they have not been separated intentionally, so then they are not susceptible to becoming Stam Yeinam, and would be protected from being in contact with a non-Jew.
We discussed Grappa, Brandy, Cognac, which is all products of grape juice and wine.
We said they all need a reliable hexer.
They all would be subject to Stam Yeinam.
However, after they've been produced, if a non-jew touched them, they would still be permissible
because they are considered Mavushal.
Through the process of their being made, they are cooked and also have a considerably different taste than wine.